et c'est vous Paul Valette bonjour vous
êtes historien politologue et chercheur
associé au Centre de sécurité politique
de Genève merci d'être avec nous on
vient de voir sur portage de notre
équipe donc déployer dans l'est de
l'Ukraine avec ses résistants d'un
nouveau genre peut-être un mot tout
d'abord de l'actualité en tout cas ce
qui nous aura animé nous les chaînes
d'infos tout le weekend avec cette
annonce cette énième annonce si je puis
dire du groupe Wagner revendiquant la
prise de de barmouth les paramilitaires
qui vont plus loin aujourd'hui et qui
annonce qu'ils vont achever le transfert
de leur position à l'armée russe le
premier juin prochain ça confirme cette
cette thèse qui est de dire que les rues
sont à l'avantage là-bas
alors on est dans effectivement dans une
bataille de communiquer de
contrecommuniquer et
même les agences de presse les mieux
renseignés sont en difficulté pour
vérifier la réalité de leur situation
dans la ville dans ce qui reste des
ruines ou designoutes et surtout les
alentours dire qu'il y a un avantage
russe paraît quand même assez difficile
à valider en ce moment puisqu'il y a
encore quelques jours notamment on avait
des informations cette fois qui
semblaient vérifier que les forces
ukrainiennes avançaient sur les flancs
et donc ce qui paraît avoir été annoncé
samedi c'est éventuellement la prise du
dernier carré de ruines au centre de la
ville mais la ten les Russes qui étaient
censé encercler backmouth ne s'est pas
refermé et semble avoir été l'objet de
contre-attaque ces derniers jours alors
je ne sais pas si peut-être un micro est
allumé à côté de vous votre ordinateur
mais on vous entend en écho donc si vous
pouvez peut-être effectuer un réglage
pour qu'on vous entende un peu mieux on
parlait donc de cette guerre de
communiquer c'est effectivement
difficile d'y voir clair pourquoi les
les paramilitaires pourquoi ce groupe
russe qui en a fait une question d'ego
finalement cette prise de la ville de
l'Est on voit bien tous les efforts
acharnés qui ont été mis dans dans les
combats là-bas pourquoi déciderait-il de
quitter les lieux du jour au lendemain
comme il l'annonce aujourd'hui
c'est difficile à comprendre mais alors
j'espère que vous m'entendez mieux merci
beaucoup merci et bien
manifestement ce qui semble aussi un non
dit dans cette histoire c'est
effectivement le chiffre des pertes qui
est absolument impossible à vérifier
de cadavres de russe oui alors on voit
bien que il n'y a plus de ville il n'y a
plus de barmut et ce qui a été pris n'a
pas grande valeur exploitable et prix à
un autre prix qui a été lui humain et on
peut on peut peut-être se demander si
les forces de Wagner encore là on n'a
pas trop idée en termes d'effectif
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien représenter
sont-ils une division un régiment un
bataillon mais les pertes auraient pu
être tels que le groupe tellement décimé
n'aurait plus d'effectivité au combat
s'il fallait poursuivre et tenter
d'exploiter cette supposée prise
d'autant qu'on est dans un contexte de
préparatif de contre-offensive
ukrainienne qu'on nous annonce depuis
des semaines entre-temps volody
mirzelinski à effectué une tournée
européenne a participé à ce G7 a obtenu
des gages de ces alliés de nouvelles
promesses de livraison d'armes notamment
ces fameux F16 américain le veto est
élevé par Joe Biden
oui alors bien sûr disons que la
situation à par contre même ne change
pas fondamentalement la situation
générale militaire du point de vue de
l'Ukraine d'ailleurs on peut s'attendre
à ce que son offensive se poursuivent
d'ailleurs sur plusieurs axes c'est une
une tactique qui les a fort bien servi
dans le passé donc darkmout même n'est
pas le seul enjeu stratégique que les
forces ukrainiennes
voudraient exploiter dans les semaines à
venir et bien sûr l'arrivée des F-16
constitue d'abord pour le présent
évidemment un énorme coup moral
qui apporte une baume au coeur
au combattant ukrainien la perspective
d'une éventuelle meilleure couverture
aérienne mais bien sûr qui
n'interviendra que dans les mois
prochains la route va être longue on
nous dit il y a d'ici à la livraison
d'ici aussi à la formation des pilotes
ça risque de prendre des mois de longs
mois même
alors oui je pense que on ne verrait pas
intervenir ces F-16 avant avant la fin
de l'été probablement entre temps bien
sûr il y a trois mois d'opérations qui
peuvent être potentiellement offensives
ou sur des temps de repos bien sûr parce
que les avances sont toujours en général
assez assez étagée dans le temps ce qui
pourrait évidemment être le rôle des
F-16 à l'automne c'est justement la
consolidation des gains territoriaux que
les Ukrainiens ont repris ont pu
effectuer et bien sûr leur accorder une
meilleure couverture et supériorité
artérielle aérienne de théâtre bien sûr
qu'il est protégerait notamment des des
nombreuses frappes aériennes que les
Russes se réalisent encore de temps à
autre on est 15 mois après le début de
cette guerre qui persiste
il y a comme une forme d'habitude
presque de lassitude parfois quand on
parle avec des Ukrainiens qui nous
explique que les bombardements ça fait
partie maintenant du quotidien que la
vie la vie suçon cours les Russes aussi
ont consolidé des positions dans dans
l'Est est-ce que ce conflit selon vous
risque de s'éterniser de s'enliser même
pour l'instant on en voit pas la fin
donc bien sûr c'est ça qui crée disons
ce sentiment ce sentiment d'ennuisement
pour le reste il nous faudrait quand
même pas négliger ce qui peut se passer
dans les prochains mois à savoir surtout
bien sûr si les contre-attaques
ukrainiennes se révèlent finalement
assez
révèle le même degré dessus c'est que ce
à quoi on a assisté à à l'automne
dernier parce que effectivement
reprendre toute la partie qui menaçait
notamment rare kif et puis et puis bien
sûr le dégagement de Gregson ça
représenté évidemment un véritable gain
pour pour les ukrainiens et une
meilleure perspective de de victoire
alors il n'est pas impossible évidemment
que des que d'autres percer puissent ce
poursuivre cet automne ce qui bien sûr
modifierait bien sûr la carte des
territoires contrôlés par les Russes et
ça ça reste particulièrement important
puisque l'objectif est bien de se saisir
du don basse et puis aussi de le relier
par un couloir terrestre jusqu'à la
Crimée et bien sûr le plus loin possible
et c'est les Ukrainiens sont en mesure
de grignoter encore ces positions qui
ont été capturées ça qu'on le veuille ou
non ça s'appe sur le long terme la
motivation des Russes pour poursuivre le
conflit alors je parle des Russes
ordinaires évidemment pas évidemment des
de la détermination du régime qui semble
être encore très importante merci
beaucoup Paul Valette d'avoir été notre
invité